Oh Josie we've spoken before and last
time we spoke and one of our fans
commented on the video that pip and
Grenn that need to have their own
spin-off show what do you think that
would look like what do you do like it
to look like what would it involve it'd
be so funny offing a lot of the times I
tweet as the character pip on Twitter
and I did his little jokey things what
ain't in Game of Thrones obviously I
just liked a little joke about but I've
been doing it quite a lot and a lot of
people like them so I would love if they
had like a little lit where spin-off
show funny stuff things what wouldn't
happen but you would find funny like me
you know putting curlers in kids here
and just there's one I could say green
come come have goodies is that what this
is big paper mache kind of thing I've
just been building for the time when I
haven't been actually seen you know when
gaming over the wall so this little
funny stuff really I think would be
really really good to see that's what
you've been doing all the time they've
been away facing White Walkers and stuff
spit in my hand slapping it on the paper
mache making it try the thing or was the
thing guys think well here pip singing
and would you be up for that
I hear people sing because I can't sing
but if I have this thing I would have to
do you know a lot of hard work and make
it make it obviously happen and like I
had to sing in ladies for example and
I'll cut I can't sing I'm when I went to
the audition I was you know I really you
know scared but I managed to get the
part and once once ladies was on-screen
I was kind of happy with the singing
samwell tarly John Bradley's character
wanted you to sing didn't know he wanted
me to sing um hello and I got ya gave it
to him straight wait no you might hear
him sing I just got a vision it's not in
the script I don't know this is just
just as well what I'm thinking but I'm
just gotten mad I've got a vision you
know things are gonna get bad later
later over
and we're gonna be around a fire this is
what I say we're gonna be around a fire
and pip start singing and and you know
we all kind of kind of like yeah you can
see that brother brotherly love who'd
kind of thing good together you know so
I think II but I think you might sing by
hope don't just because I can't sing but
I'll give it a go anyway I think you'd
be good I like I like that scene you've
got in your heads I like that I'd like
to see that on the screen definitely he
would you back in Game of Thrones to
take the throne at the very end of the
day do you think it's gonna be the
Lannisters or the Starks or the was a
Targaryen so you think it's gonna be
somebody else completely he comes out of
nowhere I would like to see Sam Samwell
on the throne but I don't think he'll
quite make it without without I don't
know he's just he's a softy he hasn't
got the fight in him
that's where KITT takes over from him
you know he would kind of back Sam but I
would like it too because obviously
we're all brothers and I would like to
be on the throne and no one else really
my brother so we didn't want to lose you
obviously it's Pip and you know you
don't want to leave either but if you
had to how would you like to meet your
maker on the show has to be push off the
wall has to be or pushed off the wall
when I'm getting eaten by the crows
and then having that image of just pick
just just their birds picking a big old
fool that's a massive that'd be splat on
there that would you wouldn't even
recognize those people I think who's
that okay yeah that or something really
really meaty what's a kind of typical
day on the Game of Thrones sense if you
could describe it to people what it's
like what you have to do in terms of I
don't know costume you makeup you know
your lines all of that sort of the set
up the camp number of people who are
there
it all starts our cars pick up pick us
up at the hotel we go to location we go
to our trailers and all our costumes
would be hanged up in our trailer still
to this day it's a bit difficult because
they've just hanged up there haven't
really labeled number one two three four
so like what to put them first so in
season three I started dressing and I
thought I had it all right and then the
lady who goes no no no that that goes on
first and that goes on last and so as a
bit of a mother so from there you get in
your costume you have some breakfast
you're going to get hair and makeup and
and then you go to you go to location or
on or set to do a little rehearsal is
quite quick and you do it and then we go
for the take and then that's it if
you've gotten no more stuff for that
date you know they send you to the hotel
or send you back to where you come from
so it's really quite quick the crudest
so many crew about it it's a bit it's a
bit intimidating but I've been Dean
acting for quite a bit now but it's
still intimidating when you're doing
your scene and it's gay my friend so
there's so many different career about
you know there's so many so it's a bit
but yeah that's the kind of a normal day
really someone someone has to help you
with your costume and then you just get
to sit and then you do your job
and a great job it is to is now you have
it sure you've been enjoying working on
the show lately it's like so every
interview I do or speak to some
understand
it's amazing by it is amazing it's just
like this is the biggest thing I've ever
done and it's a real eye-opener to you
know there's so many good actors there's
so many good people one on this set and
you're watching other taxes you're
learning stuff like I watch Tyrion a lot
is just something else
a lot of the other actors you know that
there's they all give something
different which is nice you feel like
you're learning a lot as well as you as
you're out I think on the show too from
the other actors that you're working
with yeah I do learn a lot on everything
I do
you've got the actors who I'm learning a
lot of just doing stuff where acts do
stuff small smaller because I'm usually
when I do stuff I do it too big in a
director with us sometimes say you know
just bring that down a bit or sometimes
you bring yeah I want you to raise it a
bit but I've been watching a lot of
actors do just nothing you know I mean
there's just such a small thing and it's
so powerful on screen so so hopefully if
I'm in season four and and in the future
I'm gonna be doing a bit of that it's
great that settle to you as well I know
what you mean it really makes it's just
all in the eyes you know it's just when
you're when you're staring at you know
it's just it's just all in the eyes and
it's just it's so powerful rather than
like if you if you have to be angry with
someone about your shower in every wave
run don't really give a hoot you know
about if you're if you're really
intimately intimidating and and you can
give that off to the the viewers as well
you can make the view is be scared of
you that's how come that's how come that
they hate thank you
that's how come they hate Joffrey
because he's giving that off on camera
that everyone hates him no one likes him
and this side why he's horrible was I
he's accomplished that part you know and
I it's terrific you should win in the
water if you worked if you could pick
any other characters a bit
anyone in the show who would it be Jon
Snow logic the fear I could do his part
I liked a lot to play nasty guy because
I'm not a nice guy just to pay trophy
because he's got it's got a beginning
middle end and he's his world is just
just another thing and just he's just
such a nasty guy but it's just a way he
plays obviously you could play it so
many different ways it's just amazing
and then watching that I'm learning as
well with him and he's younger than me
he's 21 I'm 30 and just when I when I
saw him do his bit what I've watched
just thought wow because obviously we
saw him in the bar we had the drink
together but I didn't know what he could
do
he was quite quiet you know and then
actually seeing these carrots come alive
I haven't seen him since I'll just like
to give him a hug and say mate that is
smashing it you know it meant to you Joe
being part of Game of Thrones words
can't describe it really to be in
something this big HBO is just is a
dream come true
and when I went for the auditions I only
had two lines I had to say and I never
read the books I was liar who's discount
- about these lines you know and it
didn't really make sense because
obviously certain of the lines they say
is obviously you know fantasy kind of
world you know so I think I had another
clue what was going on and then there
was a couple of boys and before me so I
was at the door listening to it there
okay and then I saw the door open and
they had like you had the diet the
American directors producers execs and
that and a few boys came out and none of
them were really laughing or smiling I
was like I'm quite scared you know and
then when I went in and down a little
bit they started smiling stuff I was
like maybe I got chances don't know and
then yeah I heard a few days later I got
the part and how over them - you're
lying
it must have been the image like I said
before I just fitted as the character
pip it's just been amazing it's been the
best kind of thing on my acting career
and I'm and I still I'm still kind of
because there's more to know about pip
and there's more to see and stuff and I
don't think I've done that yet you know
there's a little speech I've learned
about the law touching me something like
that that's all the meatiest seem really
he had in season one so I can't really
wait to get some yet more lines and nice
story
nice story you know what would you like
to say to all the fans of the show out
there here watching this interview I
just like to say to all the fans thank
you so much for the support you've given
me it's going to be emotional now by all
you like are just amazing on Twitter as
well think it's just the support the way
they say because I haven't read any of
the books because I am dyslexic a lot of
the people have read the book saying how
true I'm playing the part as Pippin
that's made me feel really good you know
so I just like to say thank you and yeah
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for the support and keep watching Game
of Thrones and hopefully I don't die but
if what they will do and just enjoy it
it's Game of Thrones
you